the following contest is a tag-team
match set for one fall with a 30-minute
time limit
introducing first from a location where
you need an invitation
[Music]
well Tazz before we get to this match on
hand I know you've prepared for a lot of
World Championship matches
have you ever prepared quite like
Blanche Archer was no I never took a
sledgehammer and just beat up some ran
down house yeah no he is let's all share
the murder Hulk monster is straight-up a
monster I hope the American Nightmare
Cody is ready I can't wait to see the
finals tonight to the TMC championship
the first ever TV capture that match of
course will be on double or nothing
coming up at the top of the hour
available on pay-per-view be our live or
fight TV international Yugi not want to
miss it but right now private party look
at the climb the ranks and gain
undisputed pulled over the number one
ranking in the tag team division
their opponents the team of Chuck Taylor
and
as best friends have climbed the ladder
here in aew they have won four of their
last five matches and arch five of the
last six according to our traffic there
they're on a tremendous role they've got
wins over direct Express
hey-up havoc and Sabian butcher in the
blade in 2020 they even beat one half of
the aw World Tag Team Champions Kenny
Omega when he teamed up with Michael
knockers our yeah excellent cohesive
unit is the best friends Trent and Chuck
it no doubt about it but the two young
men they're faced under this side
they're also an excellent cohesive unit
rival party and you'll see that these
two tellies for Matty's I'm sweatin each
other so this should be a pretty badass
match right here to get us ready for
double enough we saw all the way back in
October when the aew world tag team
title tournament kicked off private
party was able to shock the young bucks
coming out of the gate they had beat
that it was a number eight seed
effectively beating a number one seed
but shortly after that Tazz I think the
word got out on them pretty quickly it
did yeah you know and that's what
happens when you go in against you know
two men to that level and you're able to
dominate and do well like private party
did it it puts you on the map it on
every team's radar instantly you know
and that's exactly happened with private
party so you know I'm a family at work
I'm but I'm also a fan of best friends
work so this side this should be a heck
of a matchup and a lot of the line it's
no more contendership so it's a big deal
yeah best friends have been a very
efficient tag-team very effective
tag-team for quite a while not only here
in aew but before that in Japan on the
independent scene here in the United
States and actually globally and a
little bit of kendo therefore I like it
from Isaiah Cassady nice inside
trip right there by big Chuck E so he
gets himself a good side headlock keep
his opponent down on his back there but
he can to get that head since enough
jumps you know brushed it off able to
avoid the Hudsons are there from Isaiah
caste side headlock takeover their caste
gets the head scissor Chuck immediately
able to break free tez he didn't even
give County a chance to lace those
ankles up correct and the key with that
kick and out of that before the guy can
lock the
mr. your point is the cup to his knee
Connor and just quickly pop your hips up
and throw his leg up in the air it
sounds hard it's it just takes reps and
you know it happens very quick but
that's how you get out of that before I
got lots of zanko's marked when tagging
into a private party trent tagging in
four best friends collar-and-elbow
tie-up Trent which I'm very well I was
gonna say has a strength advantage but
when able to push Trent a step back and
take that side headlock yeah he's got it
rope his headlock keep that that near
leg back when you have a side headlock
on your opponent cover one two
Shrek kicks out well Trent actually came
up favoring his ribs grab this ribs for
sure so you know something happened
there and that's the thing you know when
you get it you show something like that
to be a target oh nice form shiver to
the jaw when going up and over the top
Northern Lights suplex walk only on one
count there yeah it was kind of like a
normal lights and kind of a fisherman
and much as he bridges very unique way
he did that throw I was very cool very
cool by Trent that kind of sound on a
chop and the guys wearing towels or a
kind of a tuxedo Jack whatever that
thing is when were you got that sound to
do that I was trying to absolutely rip
Gwen with that shot pulled back although
they're my best friend's shake of the
hands drop of the elbow and chuck et
given the folks at home a double by yeah
he's got a very unique physique and you
know those and you could see that high
above the ring that poker chip that will
go to the winner of the first ever
casino ladder match and the winner the
man who pulls down that chip will earn a
shot at the aew World Championship that
will kick off our show here tonight for
double or nothing there's a little
spoiler that's quite a little teaser I
should say right and you can only see it
on pay-per-view be our live or flight TV
double standing slice breath their
double
clothesline and beretta trennis should
say his headband can go if junior has
got to be going crazy backstage j.r jim
ross losing his mind sprint sprint was
be had banded there that's that might be
the first time ever that that trend has
lost his headband could be a real samson
and delilah situation here we'll see if
that is the source of his power or not
I'm pretty sure yeah it's not gonna slow
down but I get it yeah Trent driving the
driving his boot into the ribcage of
Isaiah Cassie Cassie though firing back
with the chop - she's a tough kid but
trance a tough veteran and he saw his
power on display there a single chop
from Trent able to take cast of the
office feet the people don't understand
like you know how much of your lower
body is uh-oh when the logic to get a
chop you'll know about it's very
important tell it hitting the baseball
when you pop your swivel your hips into
your swing same way with the entropic
your hips are a big part of it it's
putting headband on it thank goodness
thank and Trent continuing to keep the
pressure on Isaiah Cassidy tez Isaiah
Cassie and Mark on private party oh look
at this private party coming back
looking for the silly string Oh kind of
lost him a little bit on that and it
looked like crap might have buckled his
knee both overshot it a little bit but
Bret got Trent went down almost died
instead on the top of his head almost
face-first he was driven and you see
came up watching that left knee yeah and
Cassie's Kathleen Merrigan hip yeah he
didn't land all that well either
sometimes you don't you know you don't
land a move flush Lee that that's how
you get hurt even if you don't want
applying it and that's kind of what
happened so let's see what how do you
have both these athletes continue here
as private party is four and one on the
year that's how they earned that number
three ranking in the tag team division
their only loss came on January 8th on
dynamite to hangman page in kenny omega
currently the
w World Tag Team Champion yes sir no
doubt no doubt right now trapped in a
bad way here ah Quinn's dad he's got the
headband Tristana he's thought about it
it's best front Lane and some shots but
one port and ribs yeah cut
Trent off immediately with that nut shot
to the ribs and Trent doing actually a
very smart thing they're having
positioned himself under the bottom rope
yeah that's that's a very smart thing to
your points down view back with a spear
trapped look like it you play safety for
the Jaguars Wow Marc went floating over
the top of the top and caught hero and
Trent down still watching those ribs but
we see what's going on both teams at
scale that shows how important this
number one contender opportunity for the
Tag Team Championships are that's why
potential leave it all out here on the
buy-in as we your head right towards
double nothing and our champions will be
in action tonight and one half of those
double main events hangman page kenny
omega we team up with the young bucks
and matt hardy to take on Chris
Jericho's inner circle in one half part
double main events coming up at the top
of the hour
double or nothing order it now on
pay-per-view be our live or fight TV
yeah mm nothing loaded loaded card for
sure what the hell's going on here
best friends can do here big assisted
avalanche suplex thereby best friends
that was a nasty landing trek covers me
up to couldn't get all that covered Oh
Trek couldn't get all that cover cuz his
ribs are definitely affected cut the
breeze when your ribs are messed up yeah
very lackadaisical cover there by truck
but he's able to make the tag in - Chuck
Taylor Chuck providing some relief for
the best friends the powerful scoop and
a slam they write poorly elbow right
there by Chuck huh yeah I mean he tops a
couple cocky cover and an immediate 1
count there are immediate kick-out on
the one count by mark when take more
than that to put away private party a
nice chopping and comeback point with
that for I'm an outpost been exchanging
here Chuck Taylor is is deceptively
powerful in the striking department as
yeah he's compact his punches his travel
spreads nice not vertical quickly to
play down this cut is compacted like
like a compacted striker daddy a point
that is devastating striker so I agree
we don't check
we've seen Chuck Taylor legitimately
stand toe-to-toe with minora Suzuki he
hanged and got bangs I mean he didn't
get the upper hand but I'm still I mean
that's still something that's good he's
able just traded shots with one of the
toughest strikers in the world but Trent
now I didn't know that chazuke he was
the measuring stick but okay no he's not
I'm just saying black towel he ran right
into both boots
get out mark Brennan you can see Trent a
little dazed there that to the middle of
a body is confident that rib area of
Trent all right back to it now here
comes Cassidy Cassidy coming off the
beautiful gets he's Chuck at the top his
escapes through the top and middle Chuck
went to sweep the legs
Cassidy comes in with a boot nice miss
dodges Trent
hit him with the common giri and now
moonsault off the middle turnbuckles on
his feet my man is smooth Isaiah Cassidy
making it look easy task
yes yes no doubt catch me but he get it
easy and smooth man really nice coming
over the top Wow most like a cover
what'd I get
no again number one contendership
opportunities on the line right here
whatever team wins here will be the
number one contender for the aw tag team
titles and they will have a date with
hangman page and Kenny Omega in their
future that is such a huge thing for
both of these teams private party
wrestling a very effective tactic match
here tether yeah not a lot of the
shenanigans of their right they're prone
to I think you're right there's not no
tomfoolery no shenanigans it's all
business Jones and it's working
I'll watch when he watch this oh we've
seen that double foot style always works
when
one two two count only from referee Rick
Knox
you had always time enough and just stay
did you can't let a guy like trenches
late I don't like that leaving them in
the middle like that but I pull him
toward your corner that little hiccup
could see this is the problem now what a
gal ain't rent well what's this now oh
let's back off shun that back throw
Cassidy got dumped and now I'm getting
dumped as well perfect way to apply that
thrill of great hip explosion by Trent
now the opportunity to tag and choke his
job a trench rent decimating both
members of private party but most
importantly times he got to the corner
and he got the tag out to his partner he
did it didn't let his frustrations build
up anymore he knew to get shot DT and
that construct as much pressure
obviously at this point Menasha private
party really taking advantage of that
ten count shocked Taylor went for that
rising knee strike oh he missed it but
he was still able to toss Isaiah Cassidy
into mark when I think private party
might be in trouble right now you kind
of could feel a momentum going to his
best friend she's got a have a have
combination Cassidy came down high on
his head and neck and tail here we go I
think best friends have got to give the
people what they want I would never step
on that line only once and there we see
the buy-in coming up and we're in the
buy-in now but by now nothing at the top
of the hour on pay-per-view be our live
or fight TV double or nothing what the
hell is this these private party do it
Oh start thrust with the knees in the
chest
and ribs of track back to that
midsection the ribs and you get that
kind of page shoot for your intercostals
in your rib cage those little muscles
there it's tough to breathe just imagine
the pinpoint accuracy of the offensive
private party has been closed that
midsection eyes down that was great they
are very very targeted very technical
approach by private party and that could
could be the missing piece in their game
test
I'm telling that was youth right there
scalably because the momentum was going
towards best friends rapidly but that
maneuver right there really shut down
Trent and slow down
that's French Chuck Taylor and Marc
Quinn once again teeing off on each
other center of the ring and Chuck very
wisely tagging out to draw but trick
it's intercepted their bike when now
private party double boot don't catch my
Chuck he double flip and now he sends Oh
what the hell what's this now I'm not
sure what private party was doing but
Kevin somehow worked out in their favor
but no they hit the qi9 Jess yeah big
time respect right there to crime time
shout out to chef g9 that was pretty
cool it did that sling blade but
Cassio's broke Trent across his own back
and now mark when headed up to the top
you see Trent still dazed on the canvas
hold this rib no good job by Chuck man
to save his partner great awareness by
Charlie just spiked Quinn on the floor
just absolutely starts with a thumb
drive from chesty ramp right into that
kick yeah take another look at that
piledriver on the floor
shooting stars for us was insane right
on those injured ribs of Trent oh my god
that was so serious if Chuck doesn't
pull them out it down we're gonna have a
private party and I'm one contender's
but you could see Trent moving very
gingerly he's having a lot of trouble
kid
yo that's how you throw up clothesline I
follow through it one two no one able to
kick out when you throw up close I like
that you don't run as the momentum for
your opponent either you follow through
like that with the lower body step
through it
Trent did it perfectly there's a lot of
mustard on that shot he took Gwen down
and I think Marc Quinn's days may be
numbered unless he can get a tag because
silly-string he's knocked silly after
that hole Dodie get it oh my pregnant
can't lift them up oh yeah usually mark
Quentin likes that stuff up NZ Gary
except he targeted the left ripka and
actually just a right hand straight
right hand these are the ribs and a
rabbit punch and Trent up in the corner
ooh
eating a whole hide out on a trend he is
in bad shape right now and I mean oh-ho
not only is he in pain you could see
Trent labored breathing Oh
stepping off his own partner's back was
Isaiah Cassidy now raisin Trent up they
saw his shoulders his midsection as he
rolls them up did Cassidy and then just
left him you don't mean dude he I drove
his shoulder in lift that was pretty
cool how we did that hurts a lot of you
Trent
they're looking for the chin shoes nope
Trent able to reverse out oh so close
Chuck was holding Isaiah Cassidy on the
outside he couldn't break up Oh Burt
Dingman Oh Oh Trent
oh no that's quite up Chucky tra the
shuttle pop straw
zero one two three that unzip best
friends are your winners match the
victory for best friends right there
they are now the number one contender's
for the tag team championships charlie
held by Kendall Megan hang the page so
let's take a look at his thing engineer
xcalibur Chuck Taylor coming off the top
mark one had nowhere to go but down and
trap me have those books in deep and
that's all it took for best friends what
a match
what a freaking match